this video is brought to you by Moby let
me show you my favorite cut from 2020.
[Music]
this cut happens in the opening minutes
of first cow While most of the film is
set in the 1820s the film opens in the
present the film's first image is a
massive barge establishing a modern
setting the surrounding nature doesn't
give us any information about the time
period only the season the boats on the
river the distant sounds of ground and
air traffic in the background and the
woman's clothes are the only things that
anchor us to the present and then the
woman uncovers two skeletons a link to
sometime in the past and we get this cut
a massive jump into the past is
established with a close-up of the toe
of a boot the worn boot is immediately
recognizable as something from a bygone
era establishing the period in the same
way the woman's clothes established the
present though this image alone cannot
be placed in time it immediately feels
older to us in contrast to the following
image everything in the frame looks
decayed in contrast to the next frame it
lacks color the fallen leaves are more
dried and dead here there's no new
growth and the skeletons are in contrast
to the living human in the next frame
this doesn't just help us recognize that
we're moving back in time with this cut
it also establishes a theme that the
film touches on later but this is still
new
more nameless things around here then
you can check an elap it creates an
interesting Duality even though in the
timeline of the story this image is more
recent and closer to us than this one
this one appears newer and More Alive
doesn't seem new to me
seems old
first cow one of my favorite films from
2020 and one of the best edited films of
the year was edited by the director
Kelly reichardt I've seen many people
describe the film as gentle and much of
this certainly has to do with the
personality of the main character sorry
about your husband
I heard he didn't make it all the way
the music
and the pacing of the film but I think
there's also a gentleness in the editing
of the film and the way reichardt builds
suspense and explores the film's themes
on the surface first Cal is a simple
story about friendship but it explores
much larger and heavier themes of
environmentalism colonialism and
classism in its periphery it's how
reichardt uses the edges of the frame
and the periphery of the story in the
editing Direction and sound design to
explore these themes that gives a film
with such serious and heavy themes its
gentle feeling critical to understanding
what reichardt is doing in first Cal is
understanding how she's suggesting a
larger world and story instead of just
showing us one here's an example in the
opening scene instead of showing a
series of images that establish a modern
industrial landscape reykart uses the
sounds of the modern world in the
background to suggest it
we see the boat but we also hear a train
a highway and airplanes this alludes to
the end results of certain attitudes she
shows later in the film I disagree the
beaver here are endless it's a subtle
connection that illuminates a theme that
could have been explored in a much more
heavy-handed way but instead reichardt
uses what's in the background audibly to
gently suggest it
and leaves it to us to put together the
pieces she also does this visually like
in this scene where we can see how a
tent in the background and a man passing
on a boat are emphasized visually even
though they have nothing to do with the
plot and have nothing to do with the
action the main characters are involved
in reichardt uses a similar technique in
editing to develop a rich world of
characters in the periphery of the
protagonists here's what I mean in most
scenes in any film you have a primary
threat of action involving the
protagonist or the characters who are
the focus of the scene this action makes
up the core of the scene there may also
be elements that frame the scene like
establishing shots of the location or
the actions or reactions of extras or
Side characters things that help
contextualize the main action but these
things usually aren't given much
attention or screen time in the overall
scheme of the film what rhaegar does is
spend an extended amount of time in
these contextual moments usually
focusing on establishing the beginning
or end
around a side character here's an
example in this scene at the bar the
elements of the scene that are important
to the plot are cookie overhearing a
conversation about the cow first cow and
the territory and cookie reuniting was
King Lou hello cookie
but reichardt spends a significant
amount of time focusing on an
interaction between two Side characters
hey I'm not bothering them I'm just
asking them anonymous question what
about the Chicken and the Egg
which leads to a fight that happens off
screen and then when our protagonists
leave the scene we wait here
all right
your daddy will be back soon instead of
ending the scene when they leave
reichardt lingers for some time focusing
on the baby a character will never see
again
where most filmmakers would cut quickly
away from characters that are
essentially extras or Side characters
reichardt chooses to stay here's another
example in this scene the action that
the plot is primarily concerned with
ends
we'll have more tomorrow but instead of
cutting the scene off here reichardt
stays with a minor character who gets
cheated out of his spot in line and
doesn't get to get a cake
by doing this in scene after scene
reichart suggests a depth and richness
to the environment that surrounds the
protagonists we get a sense that there
are other stories happening around them
simultaneously in a way this approach to
storytelling is seen even in who
reichardt has chosen for her
protagonists cookie himself is the kind
of person who would normally be a side
character in a western the sort of
masculine stereotypes that are usually
the subject matter of the genre exist in
the film but they themselves are in the
background and the fringes of the story
I want to talk about how this idea
connects back to the opening cut and
another cut in the film that I love
possibly even more but to do this I'll
have to spoil the film so go watch it
before you watch the rest of this video
one of the things that's beautiful about
this opening cut that I love so much is
that it's also part of this suggestion
of important elements off screen that I
have been talking about it implies a
connection between the skeletons and the
human in the next frame it's not a
connection that you you really
understand when you first see it but as
the film wears on and you realize that
its focus is on two Central characters
it starts to Dawn on you that the two
skeletons belong to our main characters
and that this opening cut is a perverse
sort of secret match cut the vision of
these two skeletons haunts the film and
it's one of the many ways reichardt is
subtly infusing the film with suspense
that slowly builds and becomes quite
intense at the end one of these
characters at the periphery Whose desire
to get an oily cake is continually
thwarted eventually becomes the greatest
threat to the main characters caught in
their illicit milk acquisition
and pursued a threat of death oh kill
him cookie needs to lie down because of
his head injury the protagonists lay
resting in a position you might
recognize from two hours earlier in the
film and then here comes my other
favorite cut
the film ends the hard cut from the
skeletons into the past and the hard cut
from the two friends resting to Black
creates an editing pattern that
reinforces the link between the two
images the relationship between the two
allows us to infer a violent act that
happens off screen coming from a threat
at the periphery reichardt places one of
the darkest and most significant events
in the film off-screen merely suggesting
it through miseen scene and editing she
actually does this throughout the film
with any kind of violence pushing it
into the background or off screen and
this is a big part of what I think gives
the film its gentle feel even though
it's a sad story deals with some heavy
themes and is quite suspenseful these
elements are pieces reichardt gives to
you to put together yourself you
experience them as realizations implied
rather than shown
every film has some elements of plot
setting and character backstory that are
simply suggested and pushed into the
background or off screen but in first
cow reichardt puts some of the most
important aspects of the story in that
position and a big part of how she does
that is to how and when she
thank you to mubi for sponsoring this
video Ubi is an online streaming Cinema
featuring an Ever fresh collection of
hand-picked films I talked about it a
few weeks ago in a video but one of my
favorite directors yorgos lanthamos's
new short film nimic is available now on
movie movie is available in 190
countries it's available on any screen
any device anywhere and you'll never see
a single ad the movie library has
hundreds of great hand-picked films and
every day there's a new film available
for you to watch give yourself a belated
Christmas gift by signing up for a free
30-day trial of movie you can do that by
clicking the link in the description or
going to movie.com thomasflight that's
mubi.com
thomasflight for your 30-day free trial
thanks again to movie for another year
of supporting the work I do on this
channel
foreign
[Music]